Do you have any help from a 33-year-old daughter with insulin resistance?
She does not have diabetes but has several email problems with PCOS and
endometriosis. So yeah, so insulin resistance, you can have insulin resistance
even if somebody who's not overweight, even with somebody who has had a good diet
meaning that they're not like a sugar holic. I mean, typically you think it's
somebody with insulin resistance there, you know, they're prediabetic or they're
diabetic and it's because they've had to eat a really poor diet. No idea what's
the person's so to eat a good diet or not. But those are the kind of things
that you want to look at. Insulin resistance is damaged to partly the
insulin receptors, the cell membranes. Partly has to do with pancreatic function and
it has to do also with, it does tie. So it's interesting this person said it
had several email problems with PCOS and endometriosis. I would definitely run
some labs. So a Dutch test for sure is in order with this and a Cyrex array 5 would
be appropriate for this. You've got to, you've got to do some investigation. So with
anything when you're talking about, oh, why do I have insulin resistance or why
do I have PCOS or why do I have it endometriosis? You need to go to a doctor who's
asking those questions. Why do I have this? Let's investigate. A few weeks ago we
had some questions on like, what's your protocol for this or what's your protocol
for this? And I sounded like a broken record because I don't have a protocol for
that. We have to find out why you have that. So these disorders or
dysfunctions that we often call diseases are really, you know, signs that
something else is going on. So PCOS and endometriosis and
insulin resistance are signs and other things going on from a metabolic
standpoint. So we've got to dig in to find out what the reasons why those are.
And that's where we have to run some tests. And I know some people are like, oh gosh,
these tests are expensive. Okay, well, you're never going to get to the root of
things unless you dig in and figure this out. So I would definitely run some tests.
Definitely, our chronic disease and autoimmune course would be good and a good
case review, whether you would be a good thing to do too.